je vous propose que
ce matin Monsieur Frédéric veau qui le
directeur général de la police nationale
je rappelle dans quel contexte cette
édition a lieu
il y a un projet de réorganisation de la
police nationale
singulièrement je simplifierais le
propos en disant la volonté de
départementaliser l'ensemble des
services ce qui n'est naturellement est
un élément extrêmement nouveau dans par
rapport à l'organisation actuelle et
qu'un certain nombre d'inquiétudes se
sont fait entendre et tout
particulièrement par la police
judiciaire voire même par un certain
nombre de magistrats inquiets de cette
évolution
nous avons décidé ensemble il y a 15
jours précisément de créer une mission
d'information afin de mieux comprendre
la situation de rapporteurs Madame
bellureau et Monsieur Durand sont
présents Monsieur le Directeur et vous
poseront sans doute un certain nombre de
questions et l'objectif maintenant est
de vous laisser la parole pour nous
expliquer
la procédure dans laquelle vous êtes
engagé la réforme dans laquelle vous
êtes engagé puis chacun posera les
questions qui souhaitent naturellement
voilà
je vous remercie les chers collègues de
votre attention et je laisse la parole à
Monsieur le Directeur Général
merci monsieur le Président Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs mesdames
messenatrices messieurs les sénateurs la
police nationale fait face à de nombreux
défis grâce notamment à la capacité
d'adaptation au courage et à
l'engagement de ces personnels je vous
coupe un instant pour vous dire que
cette audition est retransmise en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat pardon
donc grâce au courage et un engagement
de ces personnels dans un environnement
toujours plus complexe et
particulièrement exposée comme
l'actualité nous le rappelle
malheureusement trop régulièrement les
efforts budgétaires exceptionnels
consentis par la nation au cours des
deux derniers exercices et dans le cadre
de la Love Me dans l'hypothèse où elle
serait adoptée par le Parlement
permettent de disposer de moyens et
d'équipements qui nous rendent plus
performants il nous conduisent à
envisager l'avenir avec confiance
nous avons donc le devoir d'être encore
plus efficace
la réforme de l'organisation de la
police judiciaire que votre commission
va examiner dans le cadre de la mission
d'information s'inscrit dans une réforme
plus vaste et ambitieuse de
l'organisation et de la gouvernance de
la police nationale importante non
seulement pour ces agents mais aussi
pour toutes celles et tous ceux qui
aspirent légitimement à bénéficier du
meilleur service public dans le domaine
de la sécurité intérieure
la dernière grande réforme de la police
nationale remonte à 1966 actant la
fusion de la Sûreté nationale et de la
préfecture de police pour créer la
direction générale de la police
nationale
plusieurs adaptations ont été réalisées
depuis cette date mais la structuration
de la police nationale n'a pas été
fondamentalement modifiée notre
organisation actuelle avec des
directions centrales toutes assez
autonome et un fonctionnement très
vertical et peu adapté au défi auxquels
nous devons faire face qui appelle un
pilotage coordonné de chacun des métiers
est nécessaire décloisonnement et
davantage de déconcentration pour
travailler le plus possible autour de
problématiques territoriales
l'idée d'unifier la police nationale au
niveau départemental avait déjà été
tenté dans les années 90
certaines directions n'y étaient pas
associées comme la direction centrale de
la police judiciaire je ne m'engagerai
pas dans l'analyse des raisons de
l'échec de cette tentative qui était
aussi la conséquence d'une alternance
politique
le constat d'une organisation qui peut
être améliorée et partagée depuis
longtemps par de nombreux acteurs ou des
observateurs des questions de sécurité
intérieure
le Livre blanc de la sécurité intérieure
publiée à l'automne 2020 aborde
notamment le sujet de l'organisation de
la police nationale résumée en quelques
phrases dans la synthèse du document
final dont je vous livre un extrait les
forces de sécurité intérieure doivent
appréhender leurs missions selon une
approche plus intégrée
d'autres institutions ont pu établir un
constat identique et appelé à une
réforme des structures
le rapport de la commission d'enquête du
Sénat relative à l'état des forces de
sécurité intérieure conduite en 2018
sous la présidence de monsieur le
sénateur Michel Boutan rapporteur
monsieur sénateur François Grosdidier
avait émis de nombreuses propositions
sur la base du constat je cite
d'une organisation en tuyau d'orgue
soulignant que la police nationale
souffre de sa forte segmentation et d'un
manque pas tant de cohésion qui pèse au
quotidien sur les agents comme sur
l'efficacité des services
constatant aussi je cite là encore qu'un
tel cloisonnement se vérifie également
au niveau territorial
déplorons également je cite là encore
que ce fonctionnement en silo nuit
indéniablement à l'exercice d'un
véritable pilotage ainsi qu'à la
définition d'une stratégie globale
d'emploi des forces de police sur le
territoire
dans leur rapport du 3 juillet 2019
relatif à la situation les missions et
les moyens des forces de sécurité les
députés Jean-Michel Fauvergue et
Christophe nedjlen ont également évoqué
la nécessaire réorganisation sur la base
du constat d'un morcellement des
services préconisant je cite encore la
restructuration des forces de sécurité
en grande direction par métier pour
mettre fin au fonctionnement en tuyau
d'orgue tout en redonnant des marges de
manœuvre aux responsables locaux
je peux également mentionner le référé
de la Cour des comptes du 22 décembre
relatif à la fonction de police
judiciaire dans la police et la
gendarmerie nationale qui notait un
fonctionnement cloisonné des services
d'enquête de la direction centrale de la
sécurité publique et de la direction
centrale de la police du Sierre et
proposer de ne pas écarter l'hypothèse
d'une réforme de l'organisation
territoriale de la police nationale
visant à intégrer dans un même réseau
les services de la DCSP et de la DCPJ en
les dotant localement d'un commandement
commun selon le modèle en vigueur à
Paris et dans sa petite couronne
forte de près de 150 000 personnels dont
plus de 30000 à la préfecture de police
et 4700 à la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure la police nationale
des GPN est préfecture de police
comprise traite environ 70% de la
délinquance générale et plus de 83% de
la grande criminalité
je n'aborderai pas dans le cadre de
votre mission l'organisation
particulière de la préfecture de police
de Paris qui n'est pas concerné par
cette réforme et qui présente une
organisation proche de ce que nous
voulons mettre en place même si elle
n'est pas aboutie en raison du
traitement d'une partie de la
délinquance par une direction un peu
équivalente à la direction centrale de
la sécurité publique la direction de la
sécurité de proximité de l'agglomération
parisienne
pour ce qui concerne les services placés
sous mon autorité directe deux
directions couvrent l'essentiel des
missions de police judiciaire la
direction centrale de la sécurité
publique direction généraliste qui est
la plus grande direction active de la
police nationale en terme d'effectif
qui compte plus de 65 000 personnels
dont
17,17400 sont affectés dans la filière
judiciaire répartie dans 286
conscriptions de sécurité publique et 92
direction départementale de la sécurité
publique et qui traite quantitativement
la part la plus importante des
infractions enregistrées par les
services de police
la direction centrale de la police
judiciaire direction spécialisée chargée
de lutter contre la criminité organisée
le terrorisme la cybercriminalité ainsi
que les formes graves et complexes de la
délinquance spécialisée elle est
composée de 5640 personnels dont 3800
enquêteurs répartis dans des services
centraux et territoriaux services
centraux organisé autour de notamment de
quatre sous-directions opérationnelles
que je cite très rapidement la
sous-direction de la lutte contre la
criminalité organisée la sous-direction
de la lutte contre la criminalité
financière la sous-direction
antiterroriste la sous-direction de la
lutte contre la cybercriminalité et
enfin l'Office anti stupéfiant rattaché
directement au Directeur Central de la
police judiciaire
l'organisation territoriale de la DCPJ
compte cette direction zonale 18
directions territoriales et 39 services
de police judiciaire
je ne peux pas ne pas mentionner le
service national de police scientifique
1245 personnels qui pilote l'ensemble de
la police technique et scientifique de
la police nationale et les laboratoires
de pollution scientifiques qui
concourent à l'efficacité évidemment de
tous les services d'investigation
à ma connaissance personne ne semble
contester le fait que notre organisation
est cloisonnée est très centralisée
entraînant de fait la cohabitation sera
même territoire de service qui relèvent
d'une même direction de direction
différente pardon avec chacun son
directeur et son état-major des bases de
données qui ne sont pas toutes partagées
des outils métiers différents des
priorités une stratégie qui leur sont
propres il en découle des conflits de
compétences positifs ou négatives des
doublons et parfois des logiques de
concurrence qui nous font perdre en
efficience
la lisibilité et la compréhension de
l'organisation de la police nationale
sont également très difficiles pour nos
partenaires et nos interlocuteurs en
particulier les élus et la population
par ailleurs l'exercice d'une même
mission aujourd'hui répartie entre
plusieurs directions
par exemple très compliqué voir
impossible de concevoir une stratégie
globale en particulier pour la mission
de police judiciaire
pour surmonter cette difficulté nous
avons donc signé des protocoles entre
les services de la police nationale pour
tenter d'harmoniser nos pratiques et
coordonner nos actions le dernier
d'entre eux date du 12 avril 2016 et
porte sur la doctrine de coordination de
l'investigation entre les services
territoriaux de la sécurité publique et
de la police judiciaire je ne suis pas
certain qu'il ait été vraiment mis en
œuvre
même s'ils ont apporté malgré tout un
peu de fluidité la multiplication de ces
protocoles et révélatrice de la
faiblesse de notre organisation on peut
trouver de bonnes raisons à conclure des
protocoles avec la gendarmerie les
polices municipales l'éducation
nationale ou les pompiers mais
protocolisé dans la même institution et
bien l'illustration d'un défaut
d'organisation
cette réforme est particulièrement
nécessaire pour la filière police
judiciaire confrontée à de grandes
difficultés
les causes de la crise que connaît cette
filière sont multiples dû notamment à
une complexification excessive et
toujours plus grande de la procédure
pénale et une politique des ressources
humaines peu adaptée aux spécificités de
ces métiers cause que nous avons
identifié en 2020 dans le cadre du
initiative de la direction générale de
la police nationale rassemblant tous les
services autour d'une coordination
nationale de l'investigation
un certain nombre de ces facteurs a
contribué à ce que la filière
investigation de la police nationale
soit malheureusement moins efficace
qu'elle n'a plus l'être dans le passé
sur la période sur la période
2010-2019 je ne prends pas en
considération l'année 2020 qui est
singulière en raison de la crise
sanitaire le volume global de la
délinquance traité par les services de
police à varier assez peu avec une
moyenne de 2,4 millions de fait
enregistrés par an
il convient de souligner que la
direction centrale de la sécurité
publique traite l'essentiel de la
délinquance enregistrée par la police
nationale y compris pour l'effet
relevant de la criminalité organisée
59% de l'agrégat de la grande
criminalité pour la DCSP contre
seulement 8% par la DCPJ et 29% pour la
préfecture de police
toujours sur la période de 2010-2019 les
taux d'hélicitations ont baissé de
manière constante et significative quel
que soit l'agrégat concerné atteinte
bien à tête aux personnes ou délinquance
économiques et financière
moins 12 points pour les violences non
capuleuses moins 15 points pour les
violences sexuelles
moins de points pour les atteintsobiens
qui sont déjà très faiblement élucidés -
16 points pour les infractions
économiques et financières
cette évolution n'est donc pas la
conséquence d'une augmentation du volume
des faits à traiter
la baisse de la performance globale de
la filière contribue aussi en partie à
la constitution de stocks de procédures
dans les services généralistes au mois
de juin 2022 le nombre total des
procédures merci monsieur le Président
le nombre total des procédures en
portefeuille pour les services de la
direction centrale de la sécurité
publique s'élever à plus d'un million
500 000 soit une moyenne de 104
procédures par enquêteurs avec de fortes
disparités selon les départements
par ailleurs j'entends certains
magistrats dire publiquement que la
qualité des procédures est en baisse et
exprimer le constat d'un retrait de
l'encadrement officier et commissaire
dans la conduite des enquêtes il est
vrai que les policiers du corps
d'encadrement et d'applications qui
constituent aujourd'hui l'ossature de la
filière investigation des services de la
sécurité publique ne sont pas assez
formés et insuffisamment encadré
ce dernier point est à mettre en
relation avec le faible taux
d'encadrement des services
d'investigation généraliste 5% pour les
directions centrales de la sécurité
publique contre environ 30% pour la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire conséquence directe de la
déflation des corps d'officiers et de
commissaire
en général la réponse attendue aux
difficultés s'exprime souvent sous la
forme de demande de renfort qui sont
parfois nécessaires même s'ils ne sont
pas tous porteurs de la solution
en effet en ce qui concerne
l'investigation on observe que la hausse
des effectifs des enquêteurs plus 17%
entre 2015 et 2020 n'a pas été
suffisante pour enrayer cette crise
or préfecture de police la filière
investigation de la direction générale
de la police nationale était ainsi
composée de 21300 enquêteurs en 2020
pour 17800 en 2015 cette hausse
concernant non seulement la direction
centrale de la sécurité publique
mais aussi la DCPJ de l'ordre de 20% en
plus
on ne peut donc pas réduire la question
de la crise à la seule question des
moyens alloués à la filière la question
de son pilotage global doit être posée
et ne pourra se résoudre dans le cadre
de notre organisation actuelle qui doit
impérativement évoluer
j'ouvre quand même une petite parenthèse
pour ne pas laisser penser non plus que
ce constat n'est que négatif l'activité
des services d'investigation de la
police nationale ayant été très
fortement dirigés vers la lutte contre
les trafics de stupéfiants et contre le
terrorisme pendant cette période
évidemment très très singulière
cette démarche de transformation de la
police nationale a été initié dès le
mois de janvier 2020 avec la création de
trois directions territoriales de la
police nationale en outre-mer
des directions territoriales de la
police nationale ont été
mises en place le 1er janvier 2020 à
Mayotte en Nouvelle-Calédonie et en
Guyane département qui comptait alors
une direction départementale de la
sécurité publique une direction
départementale de la police frontière
une antenne de police judiciaires et une
antenne de l'Office anti-supéfiant puis
à la Réunion en Guadeloupe Martinique et
Polynésie le 1er janvier 2022
les raisons avancées à l'époque
conservent toutes leurs pertinence
puisqu'il s'agissait notamment je cite
dans le cadre du rapport de présentation
du décret de création d'améliorer
l'efficacité de la gouvernance en
développant un pilotage et une vision
unique de l'activité policière cette
unité de commandement permettant de
dépasser l'organisation en silo des
directions centrales et de fonctionner
davantage dans une logique métier sur
ces territoires délimités
des enseignements sont tirés de ce qui
ne relevait donc pas d'une
expérimentation mais bien d'une mise en
œuvre concrète
plus de solidarité entre les services et
de fluidité dans le travail quotidien la
simplification représentée par le fait
de n'avoir qu'un seul interlocuteur pour
toute la police nationale qui dispose de
l'ensemble des leviers et des métiers de
la police pour répondre aux
préoccupations
la disparition des logiques de
concurrence entre services et une
meilleure prise en charge des victimes
grâce à des services territoriaux de
police judiciaires mieux organisées et
plus réactif un meilleur suivi des
dossiers et une plus forte implication
de la chaîne hiérarchique dans la
gestion des portefeuilles de toute la
filière permettant de rétablir
localement des situations en s'appuyant
sur le savoir-faire de la police
judiciaire en ce qui concerne la Guyane
la police nationale dispose désormais
dans ces territoires d'une capacité de
mobilisation plus importante sans que
l'expertise de la police judiciaire ne
soit remise en cause ou que ses moyens
soient réorientés vers le traitement de
la délinquance de masse
en métropole 8 expérimentations à droit
constance sont menées dans le
Pas-de-Calais les Pyrénées-Orientales la
Savoie depuis le mois de janvier 2021 et
dans le Calvados les rôles l'Oise le
Puy-de-Dôme et le Haut-Rhin depuis le
mois de février 2022
la particularité que nous possédons à
ces expérimentations à droit constant
avec un fonctionnement moins intégré
l'efficacité du dispositif reposant
principalement sur la bonne volonté des
personnes concernées
nous enregistrons cependant des progrès
opérationnels significatifs
grâce à un regroupement des différents
états majors en un seul compétent pour
toute la police nationale avec un
partage exhaustif des informations entre
les filières et la capacité à mettre en
place une stratégie globale à l'échelle
du territoire des opérations associées
mieux les diverses spécialités de la
police et ensuite quelques
problèmes très résiduels mais qui
handicapait énormément les services de
police jusqu'à maintenant une conférence
radio unique pour toutes les directions
de façon à mutualiser les moyens et
d'accroître le nombre de patrouilles
disponibles en cas d'intervention
complexe
et enfin la prise en charge des
déferlement au tribunal par des
effectifs en tenue alors que jusqu'à
lors les enquêteurs avaient l'obligation
de les assurer
un des objectifs de cette réorganisation
et de rendre le travail de tous les
policiers plus simples et plus fluides
pas de concurrence entre service renoncé
à des actions conduites sur la base
d'information parcellaires détenus par
chacune des directions des réponses plus
rapides de la chaîne hiérarchique des
possibilités d'évolution professionnelle
à l'intérieur d'une filière ou entre
filière plus facile en fonction des
aptitudes et de la motivation une
politique de formation continue plus
proche des besoins du terrain de
véritables parcours de carrière pour
disposer de profils plus diversifiés et
polyvalent des capacités de renfort plus
importantes en cas de coupure
opérationnel
nous aspirons à une police plus efficace
plus proche des victimes capables de
réaliser des enquêtes de qualité quel
que soit la nature des infractions
la future organisation permettra un
pilotage coordonné de la filière police
judiciaire non seulement pour orienter
l'activité opérationnelle des services
mais également pour améliorer la
conception et la mise à disposition à la
disposition de tous les enquêteurs de
référentiel professionnel commun et
d'outils numériques qui seront de nature
à simplifier leur activité
l'identification précise des besoins en
formation et la mise en place de modules
de formation en adéquation avec ses
besoins le suivi des portefeuilles
d'affaires pour identifier rapidement
les services en difficulté et mettre en
place des dispositifs de soutien ce
pilotage unique difficile à mettre en
place actuellement en raison de
l'éclatement des services sera également
de nature à accélérer la modernisation
de nos méthodes de traitement du
renseignement criminel et plus largement
de la circulation de l'information
opérationnelle
il nous permettra par ailleurs de
garantir une bonne allocation des moyens
grâce à une vision plus précise des
niveaux d'activité et des charges des
services
on peut pas négliger non plus que la
mutualisation des états majors des
structures d'analyses et des fonctions
support pourra conduire à la réalisation
d'économies dans le domaine de
l'équipement et des gains sur des
fonctions redondantes
enfin nous souhaitons moderniser la
gestion des ressources humaines créant
de nouvelles perspectives d'évolution
professionnelle pour tous grâce à une RH
unifiée offrant des parcours plus
diversifiés plus enrichissants avec un
processus de décision plus rapide
dans l'attente du projet définitif les
grandes lignes de cette réorganisation
ont été affinées à partir des retours du
terrain
le niveau des directions nationales ne
doit plus être un échelon de gestion des
personnels mais essentiellement de
stratégie et de pilotage
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
directions centrales deviendront des
directions nationales chargées de
définir et d'animer l'activité des
quatre grandes filières métiers de la
police nationale la sécurité et la paix
public le renseignement territorial la
police judiciaire les frontières et
l'immigration irrégulière
les directeurs disposeront d'une
capacité de pilotage stratégique sur
l'ensemble du métier concerné ils auront
également placé directement sous leur
autorité des entités nationales
opérationnelles
en ce qui concerne la future direction
nationale de la police judiciaire les
offices centraux et les autres services
à compétence nationale ou de soutien
opéra opérationnels seront maintenus
certains d'entre eux comme l'office et
cyber ou d'autres verront leurs
attributions et leurs moyens renforcés
ces filières seront déclinées au niveau
zonal et au niveau départemental dans
des configurations différentes d'un
territoire à l'autre tenant compte des
spécificités de la criminalité et des
enjeux sécurité
le niveau zonal permettra à la direction
générale de la police nationale d'avoir
un relais territorial pour animer et
coordonner l'action des directions
départementales dans le strict respect
j'insiste là-dessus des prérogatives des
préfets et de l'autorité judiciaire
pour la filière police judiciaire il est
envisagé d'y implanter certaines
structures de soutien opérationnel comme
les brigades de recherche et
d'intervention le service
interministériel d'assistante technique
des fonctions cyberres qui est difficile
de multiplier à l'infini l'aspect saisie
des avoirs criminels et un service
chargé des enquêtes sur les atteintes à
la probité dont nous avons compris
quelle suscité une forte inquiétude en
raison de son rattachement au niveau
départemental
le directeur zonal sera assisté
d'adjoint en charge des filières métiers
dont un pour la police judiciaire qui
veillera à ce que tous les services
territoriaux de PJ fonctionnent selon
les règles fixées par une doctrine les 4
futurs filières métiers disposeront
chacun effectivement d'une doctrine
d'emploi et de fonctionnement permettant
ainsi à chacun de connaître précisément
le périmètre des missions à signer
cette méthode a été instaurée en 2013
cette méthode de la doctrine pour
définir le cadre d'action du
renseignement territorial jusque là ce
service ne disposait d'aucune doctrine
ces missions et son organisation
fluctuant au gré des priorités ce
document a ainsi permis d'empêcher que
certains directeurs départemental
départementaux pardon soit tentés de
confier aux policiers de ce service des
missions qui ne relevaient pas de leurs
compétences
enfin le niveau départemental sera
l'échelon territoriale de référence pour
l'animation et la coordination
opérationnelle de l'action de l'ensemble
des services implantés sur ce territoire
sans préjudice de la compétence inter
départementale des futurs services de
politiciens qui sera préservé
pour le service inter départemental de
la police judiciaire qui verrait ses
marges de manœuvre anormalement
contrarié par le directeur départemental
de la police nationale du lieu de son
implantation le dzpj aura pour mission
de veiller au respect des règles de
fonctionnement
la chaîne est hiérarchique en lien
étroit et permanent avec l'autorité
judiciaire devra garantir la meilleure
réponse possible au département
limitrophes dont les capacités d'enquête
pourraient être limitées
sous l'autorité des directeurs
départementaux de la police nationale
les circonscriptions de sécurité
publique deviendront des
circonscriptions de police nationale
ce regroupement des missions de police
judiciaires dans une seule filière
favorisera le meilleur niveau de
spécialisation des services d'enquête en
tout point du territoire national
le maintien de l'empreinte territoriale
et de l'expertise de l'actuel direction
centrale de la police dissière est
essentielle car nous disposons en effet
de pôle d'excellence en police
judiciaire
constitué actuellement de plus de 5000
personnels la future direction nationale
de la police judiciaire animera et
pilotera demain le travail de plus de
23000 enquêteurs avec une vue et une
approche globale qui ne pourront qu'être
bénéfique à l'ensemble
contrairement à ce qui peut être dit ou
écrit les structures de la police
judiciaire ne disparaîtront pas elles
seront maintenues partout où il existe
aujourd'hui une implantation d'un
service de police judiciaire le parquet
ou le juge d'instruction aura donc
évidemment toujours le libre choix de la
formation qu'il souhaite saisir
l'autorité judiciaire continuera à
exercer sa mission de direction et de
contrôle de la police judiciaire
pour l'autorité judiciaire la réforme
évitera le risque de conflit négatif de
compétences auxquelles les parquets sont
parfois confrontés lorsqu aucun des
services d'encaisses du ressort ne
souhaite traiter une saisine
enfin les directeurs départementaux de
la police nationale seront choisis pour
leur aptitude à prendre en compte toutes
les filières métiers de la police
nationale
l'idéepn de demain ne seront pas
systématiquement les DDSP d'aujourd'hui
ce sont des profils qui seront
identifiés et issus de toutes les
directions actuelles pour exercer un
nouveau métier celui de chef de police
notre système d'évaluation des cadres de
la police nationale a été renforcée en
nous inspirant du dispositif du xat
l'évaluation à 360 degrés en vigueur
pour les membres du corps préfectoral
car le choix des femmes et des hommes
qui dirigeront ces directions
départementales et déterminant pour la
réussite de cette transformation
afin de dissiper certaines inquiétudes
j'ai tenu adresser un courrier à chacun
des agents de la direction centrale de
la police judiciaire pour expliquer le
sens de la réforme et prendre un certain
nombre d'engagements que je souhaite
rappeler devant vous
les enquêteurs de la police judiciaire
continueront à agir en dehors de leur
territoire d'affectation sur la base de
compétences judiciaires élargies
les capacités opérationnelles
spécialisées dont dispose aujourd'hui la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire seront renforcés
la doctrine garantira notamment les
capacités d'initiatives et la
préservation du temps long nécessaire à
l'aboutissement des affaires les plus
complexes
les effectifs relevant aujourd'hui du
périmètre de la direction centrale de la
police judiciaire ne seront pas mis à
contribution pour traiter les stocks de
procédures et enfin j'insiste là-dessus
aucun agent de la politicienne ne sera
contraint de changer de métier ou de
résidence administrative
nous souhaitons que cette nouvelle
organisation soit mise en place au cours
de l'année 2023
soit plus de deux ans après le début des
travaux et avant l'échéance de l'année
sans doute difficile pour les forces de
sécurité intérieure des Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques
en conclusion de ce propos introductif
peut-être un peu trop long pardonnez-moi
monsieur le président
je veux être très clair et très ferme à
propos de la direction centrale de la
police judiciaire et de ma détermination
intacte et totale à lutter contre la
criminalité organisée et à faire traiter
les faits les plus graves par les
services spécialisés
toute réforme suscite des inquiétudes et
des interrogations je les entends et je
les comprends
elles ne doivent cependant pas nous
faire perdre de vue l'essentiel la
réforme de l'organisation de la police
nationale est nécessaire pour permettre
aux personnel d'accomplir leur mission
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
au magistrat de disposer de services
encore plus efficaces capables de
produire des procédures de meilleure
qualité quelle que soit l'infraction
concernées et aux victimes d'être prise
en charge à la mesure de préjudice et du
traumatisme qu'elle subisse
je vous ai présenté des éléments issus
de constats de rapport et
d'expérimentation qui font de ce projet
de réforme
ma conviction est aussi très personnelle
après avoir servi pendant 30 années en
police judiciaire dans des services
opérationnels territoriaux et centraux
spécialisés dans la lutte contre la
criminalité organisée ou le terrorisme
je suis en train dans la police pour
faire de la police judiciaire
je connais la valeur des femmes et des
hommes avec qui nous avons fait face à
des situations très difficiles et
résolues bon nombre d'affaires très
complexes
je ne pourrais pas imaginer les trahir
et renoncer à l'idéal qui m'anime
toujours et que nous avons partagé
je peux donc vous affirmer que non les
services de la direction centrale de la
politique ne vont évidemment pas
disparaître
dans certains territoires et pour
certains contentieux ils seront même
renforcés
oui l'autorité judiciaire aura toujours
la même capacité à choisir la formation
qui lui paraît être la mieux à même de
traiter un dossier et d'exercer son
contrôle sur les services de police en
charge de l'investigation
oui nous allons bâtir une organisation
qui nous permette de mettre un terme aux
défaut relevé par toutes les
institutions qui se sont penchées sur
notre fonctionnement afin de répondre
encore mieux aux nombreux défis que nous
impose l'exigence de protection des
personnes et des biens les aspirations
légitimes des victimes et la protection
des libertés individuelles et
collectives
merci Monsieur le Directeur je ne la
parole au rapporteur madame bellureau
puis monsieur Durand ensuite nous avons
noté l'intervention de la Mercier
monsieur bonne Carrère Monsieur Alain
Marc j'ai tellement
monsieur Sueur et Madame haribet
et d'autres s'il le souhaitent madame
bellerault merci beaucoup donc il me
revient de commencer merci beaucoup de
cette présentation monsieur directeur
alors je dois dire que c'était pas
c'était complet mais il va falloir
attendre digestion par rapport à tout ce
que vous nous avez dit parce que si vous
voulez on a un certain nombre de
questions manifestement vous avez
répondu à certaines mais ne m'en
veuillez pas si je reviens un peu sur ce
que vous avez pu dire et vous faire
éventuellement expliciter un peu plus et
de façon un peu plus détaillée et
technique pour des des parlementaires
qui ne sont pas depuis 30 ans policiers
et qui auront besoin de comprendre de
façon très pratique comment ça
fonctionne
tout d'abord juste le calendrier vous
avez rappelé la genèse de tout ça vous
nous avez parlé du calendrier j'ai
entendu que c'était court de l'année
2023 donc elle sait à dire que ça ne
sera pas au 1er janvier 2023 et que donc
les choses peuvent encore être
réfléchies et travailler ou n'avons plus
que trois mois ça son importance aussi
pour une mission d'information
vous nous avez également dit en quelques
mots les expérimentations que vous avez
en cours sur le territoire l'outre-mer
c'est une mise en œuvre et les huit
départements sont en expérimentation
est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire
ce que vous avez pu constater de façon
très pratique en termes d'amélioration
c'est à dire que vraiment ça a apporté
j'ai bien compris que l'idée c'est
unification voilà mais
et également également tout simplement
aussi les difficultés parce que tout
n'est pas toujours facile et ne se gère
pas toujours d'un coup de baguette
magique donc ce retour sur les
expérimentations et également vous en
avez parlé il y a des craintes en effet
et tout le monde ici nous le savons des
craintes de la police judiciaire de voir
se diluer leur coeur de métier à savoir
la lutte contre la grande criminalité et
le terrorisme et vous vous avez dit que
il n'avait pas lieu de s'inquiéter
moi j'aimerais connaître d'abord comment
vraiment vous l'avez dit en quelques
mots et revenir sur ces sur ces craintes
vous engager que il ne perdrait pas
parce que ils nous disent que ils ont
l'inquiétude de voir cette fonction
ne plus être entière et d'être amené à
avoir d'autres activités
et également comment alors cette
direction qui s'appellera direction
nationale de la police judiciaire qui
est actuellement doté la direction
centrale de la PJ si je me trompe pas de
8 offices centraux et d'organes de
coopération internationale policière
pour lutter contre cette grande
criminalité comment va ce corps redonner
cette vie ensemble et également le
prolongement territorial aujourd'hui qui
consiste dans notre direction
interrégionnaire comment se prolongement
va se comment ça va se coordonner j'ai
bien compris que le choix de l'enquêteur
resterait soit au procure soit au juste
d'instruction c'est ça en fait voilà ce
qui ferait que le directeur
départemental ne choisit pas voilà sauf
que
oui c'est ça c'est le CPP donc faudrait
le changer si si voilà donc voilà on est
c’était une prolongement de ma question
voilà je vous remercie merci madame
monsieur Durand
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Directeur général
deux questions avec un seul préambule
pour ma part
vous nous dites monsieur le directeur
général que que les travaux sont en
cours de depuis deux ans
or on observe une levée de bouclier
assez massive avec même la création du
nouvel instance représentatif des OPJ au
sein d'une association nationale de la
police judiciaire
donc en dehors des des questions de fond
que vous avez assez longuement
détaillées on vous en remercie il y a
sans doute un sujet de méthode qu'on ne
peut pas réduire à incorporatisme ce
serait
injurieux pour les officiers de police
judiciaire qui s'expriment et donc il
doit renvoyer quand même à des craintes
profondes quand à l'exercice de leur
métier
c'est un pessimisme et des inquiétudes
qui sont d'ailleurs partagées au-delà
même du corps des officiers de police
judiciaire puisque la Conférence
nationale des barreaux ou la conférence
des procureurs exprime avec beaucoup de
dents les mêmes inquiétudes qui nous
interrogent sur les attendus que vous
avez présenté
mais de questions c'est le politique et
le département vous disiez hier
finalement que les préfets n'étaient pas
politiques aux fonctionnaires que que
vous êtes dans sa carrière a connu un
rapport aux politiques qui parfois doit
lui faire dire que
malgré tout il arrive que il y a une
tentation
d'influence du politique dans les
affaires administratives notamment
policière la question qui est très
concrètement posée
s'agissant d'interférence du politique
est un peu celle que d'ailleurs exprimée
Éliane houlette ancienne procureur du
PNF qui disait qu'elle avait parfois
ressenti des sentiments d'entrave à son
action dans l'affectation des moyens et
du coup est-ce qu'on n'a pas quand même
un risque d'autonomie de la police
judiciaire aujourd'hui qui serait
transformée demain en une capacité
d'arbitrage par le ddpn entre les
affaires entre le choix des dossiers ou
détriment du travail d'enquête autonome
et indépendant deuxième question elle
tient à
au ressort départemental le choix du
département comme esthon de base
vous nous avez expliqué que c'était une
logique finalement assez naturelle
vis-à-vis de l'évolution de la
criminalité de la délinquance et des
nécessités opérationnelles je vais
puiser chez François Molin la formule
suivante la criminalité a beaucoup
évolué à ce jour elle se joue à
l'échelle des inter-résions et de
l'international donc tu es un peu
contradictoire et est-ce que on risque
pas quand même avec cette logique
départementale même si vous nous avez
dit que les agents pouvaient agir en
dehors de leur territoire d'affectation
d'avoir quand même une réduction de la
capacité à se projeter sur les affaires
les plus complexes la criminalité
organisée et qui dépasse finalement les
frontières départementales vous avez
parlé c'est mon dernier mot d'un
courrier qui a été adressé à l'ensemble
de vos agents pour expliciter des choses
qui est n'était pas si clair que ça
est-ce qu'on peut en être destinataire
merci
merci de me pardonnera mais monsieur
Loïc Hervé qui rapporteur du corps
rapporteur du texte locmi nous sommes
dans l'actualité une question merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur directeur
général ma question sera très courte on
a un texte qui est sur le bureau du
Sénat qui s'appelle la loi d'orientation
de programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur la lobe me dont nous allons
parler dans les dans les jours qui
viennent qui comportent notamment dans
son rapport en Excel article premier un
certain nombre de de référence à cette
réforme il y a aussi dans le texte
lui-même la création des assistantes
d'enquête notamment ma question je le
dis d'ailleurs devant mes deux collègues
rapporteurs de la mission d'information
comment vous comptez articuler
clairement le texte love me
en préfiguration ou pas d'ailleurs de
cette réforme et cette réforme
madame Marie Mercier
merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues Monsieur le Directeur
général je voudrais vous remercier pour
votre exposé extrêmement clair d'un
homme expérimenté manifestement on voit
que vous possédez que vous maîtrisez
parfaitement bien toutes les arcanes de
la police nationale et cette heureux
vous êtes vraiment revenu sur ce
cloisonnement assez étanche des services
qui peut peut-être nuire à la protection
et à la sécurité de nos concitoyens je
voudrais revenir sur une période un peu
étrange de notre histoire très
contemporaine qui était celle du
confinement pendant confinement bien sûr
les cambriolages ont diminué mais les
violences intrafamiliales ont augmenté
la cybercriminalité augmentée
on a vu que il y avait une présence de
policiers très importante sur la voie
publique puisqu'il fallait faire des
contrôles or le cloisonnement est très
étrange donc une question m'est venue à
l'idée à ce sujet dans les différents
services il y en a un qui s'appelle la
police aux frontières donc pendant le
confinement la police aux frontières de
facto ne devait pas avoir grand chose à
faire donc je voudrais savoir si dans
l'ancien système les agents de la police
aux frontières sont allés donner un coup
de main à leurs collègues et si dans le
et sinon dans le nouveau système il y
aura cette forme de coordination et de
coopération pour aider des collègues
pardon trois questions Monsieur le
Directeur les deux premières concernent
la question des enquêteurs
vous avez première question vous avez
dans votre propos
évoqué une augmentation du nombre
d'enquêteurs
cet élément est pour votre serviteur
très paradoxal c'est pas du tout ce que
nous entendons sur le terrain ce n'est
pas ce que j'ai entendu du garde des
sceaux ou de votre propre ministre
nous avons plutôt le sentiment également
qu'il est difficile c'est ce que nous
n'entendons pas cela également de la
part des magistrats
nous avons plutôt le sentiment que la
police peine aujourd'hui à disposer
d'enquêteurs
y compris au regard de responsabilités
qui sont les leurs sur le plan
qualitatif le fait qu'il n'y ait plus
dans le processus de concours d'oral le
fait que vous soyez amené à proposer de
recruter dès le début dès le début de la
carrière me laisse je sais qu'il y a
quand même un problème à la fois de
nombre d'enquêteurs et de formation des
enquêteurs j'aimerais que vous puissiez
vous en dire un petit peu un petit peu
plus deuxième question dans le cas de la
lopine avec elle faisait référence
le week-end vous prévoyez des
assistantes bancaires
est-ce vraiment une bonne idée est-ce
que ça ne va pas rendre plus
administratif le fonctionnement de la
police est-ce que recruter des
assistants d'enquêtes n'est pas une
manière de dire que vraiment on peut pas
arriver à modifier la réforme de la
un jour
amélioré
la procédure la procédure elle-même
troisième question j'en terminerai pour
revenir au coeur de votre intervention
vous venez de nous présenter quelque
chose de très structuré pro le monde
très cohérent
dont on imagine assez volontiers que ça
entraîne quand même beaucoup de débats
internes à la police à la police les
gens vendent de voir se repositionner
combien faut de temps faudra-t-il pour
mettre à neuf une telle réforme et
finalement Monsieur le Directeur est-il
raisonnable
de manière si on a une approche
pragmatique des choses qui je crois le
cas de votre ministre il prend le manque
de vous-même est-il raisonnable au
moment où les moyens mis à disposition
de la Police Nationale vont
considérament augmenter les 15 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires pour la sécurité
intérieure est-ce vraiment est-ce que
vous n'allez pas perdre le bénéfice de
cette montée en puissance en vous
épuisant pardon je ne sais pas deux ans
trois ans quatre ans dans une dans une
réforme merci de votre
de vos éléments de réponse merci
Monsieur bonne Carrère
Monsieur alamark Merci Président
Monsieur le monsieur le directeur vous
venez d'évoquer la réforme de la police
judiciaire et le fait de traiter au
mieux les crimes et des lits constatées
nous car nous sommes près des maires
nous faisons un Costa avant de traiter
les faits il faut les prévenir et
travailler aussi au plus près des
territoires afin de prévenir et
d'investiguer
et malgré la qualité de nos policiers il
y a un vrai problème de présence sur le
terrain
et la difficulté pour les commissariats
par exemple à rassembler ne serait-ce
qu'un seul équipage le week-end cela
pose quand même question donc le travail
de police judiciaire et capitales mais
avez-vous réfléchi aussi à la présence
sur le terrain que nous souhaitons plus
forte avec peut-être une meilleure
organisation ou une augmentation des
effectifs
merci Monsieur Tony m'avez
puis monsieur Darnaud après merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général vous avez évoqué la
réforme de la ddpn
dans les territoires d'outre-mer
à partir de 2020 d'abord 3 territoires
étaient concernés Mayotte la Guyane et
la Polynésie française la commission des
lois s'est déplacée en Guyane et à
Mayotte un Guyane fin 2019 à Mayotte en
septembre 2021 et a effectivement
constaté quand l'état actuel des choses
lors de son déplacement des résultats
positifs semblaient
sembler en perspective
dans ces territoires notamment Guyane et
Mayotte vous le savez il y a
actuellement une flambée de violence
inouïe violence commise essentiellement
par
des bandes de jeunes et qui porte un
coup dur à ces territoires des déjà
fragiles et à leurs habitants
trois courtes questions
comment dans cette réorganisation mieux
répondre à ces assez flambées de
violence
perpétré par par ces bandes de jeunes
deuxième question
[Musique]
qu'en est-il de la compagnie
départementale d'intervention mise en
place à Mayotte en 2018 et qui était
censé venir en appui des forces de
l'ordre
un intervention et lutter contre ces
violences ces violences urbaines ou en
est-on
quatre années plus tard de cette
compagnie départementale
d'intervention et troisième question
quid des commissariats de mettre en
place de la nécessité de mettre en place
des commissariats notamment dans la
deuxième ville de Mayotte Congo qui
compte 30000 habitants qui n'a pas de
commissariat voir aussi de la Petite
Terre les deux communes de la petite air
comptent environ 30
000 habitants également
il a été
passer par certains que la mise en place
de commissariat permettrait de mieux
répondre à ces violences commises dans
des zones urbaines qu'en est-il de ces
de ces projections de commissariat merci
merci Monsieur d'Arnaud puis monsieur
Sueur oui merci monsieur le Président
avant toute chose je voudrais remercier
de
l'exposer qui viennent de nous être fait
et
faire bien les propos que viennent tenir
mon collègue tany Mohamed Souali et
singulièrement sur la question
guyanaise pour avoir participé à la
mission il y a deux sujets sur lesquels
je souhaiterais revenir le premier
concerne la cybercriminalité vous nous
avez dit qu'il y avait une volonté de
renforcer les moyens moyens humains
dédiés à la cybercriminalité or
aujourd'hui on voit l'explosion et
l'impact parfois dramatique que cela
peut prendre dans le secteur hospitalier
moi je viens d'un département simplement
ou la collectivité départementale a fait
l'objet récemment encore d'une
cyberattaque avec toutes les
conséquences douloureuses qui accompagne
ce sujet là et donc l'impériore
nécessité de voir les moyens renforcés
sur ces sujets est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un petit peu plus sur
notamment les moyens humains et la
réorganisation que cela pourrait générer
et puis revenir sur un propos que vous
avez eu s'agissant de l'évolution
des DSP en ddpn vous avez dit que
les DPN auraient peut-être un profil un
petit peu différent
pouvez-vous nous en dire un petit peu un
petit peu plus
autant sur les prérogatives que sur le
profil en lui-même et ce qui pourrait
différer je vous remercie
merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Directeur
Général j'étais sensible à votre propos
et je dois vous dire essentiellement au
3 dernières phrases
dans lesquelles vous vous êtes engagés
personnellement par rapport à votre
expérience
pour le reste j'ai été frappé par le ton
que vous avez employé qui m'a fait
penser à celui presque d'un avocat en
faveur de cette réforme c'est à dire que
vous avez employé le futur simple en
faisant ce sera comme ça ça va favoriser
tout ce qui est nécessaire et ça ira
forcément dans le bon sens et j'ai été
comme sidéré autant j'ai apprécié la fin
parce que vous nous dites ce que vous
avez vécu mais je me suis dit nous vous
entendons
je ne doute pas de votre sincérité pas
du tout et j'ai grand respect pour la
police nationale vous le savez depuis
très longtemps mais quand nous entendons
monsieur Mollens qui est quand même
procureur général près la Cour de
cassation ce qu'il dit à la radio mais
ce qu'il dit devant nous où il dit que
cette réforme pose un très grand
problème par rapport à la justice par
rapport au magistrat par rapport à
l'indépendance des magistrats etc et de
leur rayon d'action
je suis troublé parce que je me dis que
il y a quand même une république un
gouvernement
et comment concilier ces deux propos qui
me paraissent complètement
contradictoires
et pourquoi finalement est-ce que vous
ne prenez pas une part de ce que dit
Monsieur Mollens dans votre
argumentation est-ce qu'il y a pas une
dialectique quelque chose à retrouver
quelque chose qui permettrait un accord
qui permettrait peut-être d'avoir des
positions
absolues par rapport à une réforme dont
nous ne serons pas saisis puisque ces
réglementaires et nous avons quatre
lignes dans le rapport annexé à la loi
au projet de loi qui va nous être
présenté vous avez dit qu'il y avait une
complexité de la procédure pénale c'est
vrai mais en quoi le fait qu'il y ait
une direction départementale qui coiffe
l'ensemble
changera la complexité de la procédure
pénale
je ne comprends pas très bien voyez-vous
j'aimerais que
il y ait plus de nuances dans tout ça
c'est peut-être un peu pieux mais enfin
puisque nous avons la liberté de parole
je me permets de formuler cela je vois
pas pourquoi il y aura des compétences
judiciaires élargies
en même temps j'ai entendu mais
plusieurs collègues l'ont dit combien il
apparaissait nécessaire que la PJ
fonctionne à un niveau bien supérieur au
niveau départemental vous le savez vous
l'avez vécu c'est à dire que les
affaires auxquelles vous êtes confrontés
elles sont d'ampleur régionales
nationales internationale vous le savez
bien donc voilà je vous dis très
franchement le comment je ressens les
choses merci de m'avoir écouté merci
Madame aribet puis monsieur bar
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur général
c'est difficile ça va être un peu
redondant peut-être mais moi en effet
j'ai été très mal à l'aise par devant
votre présentation parce que en fait si
je devais résumer c'est cette réforme
elle a été bien pensée circuler il y a
rien à voir et vous êtes quand même
devant une commission des Lois du Sénat
devant des législateurs et vous avez dit
à la fin que toute réforme suscite des
inquiétudes moi j'aime bien travailler
un peu à la méthode de nos collègues
québécois qui explique qu'une réforme
pour être acceptée doit être comprise et
qu'une réforme c'est pas quelque chose
qui est
définitif et qu'il y a toujours des
dérives à une réforme et c'est pour ça
que les études d'impact
et prévoir les dérives possibles dans
une réforme c'est assez fondamental pour
pouvoir permettre
l'acceptation de la réforme et j'ai pas
senti ça du tout dans vos propos
et la preuve c'est que et je veux pas
allonger parce que beaucoup de choses
ont été dites je m'interroge aussi sur
la départementalisation je m'interroge
sur le niveau de technicité de la police
judiciaire j'ai l'impression quand même
que c'est plus un problème de ressources
humaines
que d'organisation et ça me fait penser
un peu à ces entreprises qui lorsqu'il y
a un problème au sein de l'entreprise
change l'organigramme en pensant que
tout va aller mieux parce qu'on a changé
l'organigramme c'est pas une question
d'organigramme c'est une question
beaucoup plus profonde d'adhésion de de
d'évolution des métiers et la question
essentielle c'est en effet les effectifs
la formation et l'évolution des métiers
et ça je l'ai très peu senti dans vos
propos alors pour être concrète sur la
fin de mon intervention j'aimerais quand
même vous poser une question parce que
dans la presse ce matin on a on a appris
qu'il y aurait peut-être une spécificité
du territoire corse qui serait prise en
compte dans l'application de la réforme
et que donc le gouvernement envisageait
déjà des exceptions avant même que la
règle ne soit appliquée est-ce que
quelque part ça veut pas dire que la
règle ne convient pas et que tout cela
va trop vite il fallait une réforme en
effet mais de manière beaucoup plus
concertée merci madame Monsieur Philippe
Bas puis madame Boyer puis ensuite la
parole sera à Monsieur le Directeur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur de
directeur général je vous ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'intérêt et lorsque vous
parlez de la police judiciaire on sent
que vous y mettez beaucoup de cœur et
d'expérience et je l'ai tout à fait
relever votre constat de la situation
m'a paru lucide
et il me semble que vous avez adopté un
parler vrai que tous nos collègues ont
pu entendre dans la description de ce
constat
ça n'est pas parce qu'une réforme
suscite des critiques qu'elle est
mauvaise
mais il est vrai que peut-être les
critiques peuvent servir à l'améliorer
j'ai entendu dans votre propos à un
certain nombre de clarifications qui
étaient nécessaires ou de rappel qu'il
ne l'était pas moi notamment sur
l'autorité des parquets
sur le déroulement des enquêtes et comme
vous l'avez souligné c'est une exigence
du code de procédure pénale qu'une
réforme d'organisation ne saurait
remettre en cause encore faut-il que les
organisations soient bien compatibles
avec cette exigence et je pense que vous
y avez réfléchi que les évolutions que
vous pouvez imprimer à cette nouvelle
organisation pourront encore conforter
cela moi j'ai deux types de questions
qui rejoignent d'ailleurs
l'intervention d'autres collègues
la première catégorie de questions
comme des états généraux de la justice
l'ont dit aussi vous évoquez la
simplification de la procédure pénale
et je crois qu'il y a un consensus sur
ce point simplement en évoque toujours
cette question
en considérant que une fois qu'on a dit
il faut refaire un code de procédure
pénale plus simple
on a tout dit est-ce que vous pourriez
nous donner quelques pistes de ce qui
vous paraîtrait indispensable pour
faciliter la tâche des enquêteurs tout
en maintenant les protections
nécessaires pour les personnes qui font
l'objet des enquêtes puis le deuxième
point c'est me semble-t-il
un point que vous n'avez pas
suffisamment à mes yeux abordés
et je rejoins monsieur bonne Carrère et
peut-être aussi
mes collègues socialistes sur ce point
moi j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'il y a
une crise d'évocation
j'ai plutôt l'impression que la police
judiciaire qui était à l'intérieur de la
police nationale tout de même
une activité particulièrement noble et
recherché
est aujourd'hui délaissé
mais si je me trompe faut me le dire
parce que
si je le dis c'est parce que j'entends
les procureurs
j'entends certains et directeurs
départementaux certains responsables des
services
régionaux de police judiciaire et je
m'inquiète
parce qu'en effet je continue moi à
penser que cette tâche est parmi les
plus nobles de la police les plus
exigeantes et je me demande s'il n'y a
pas une évolution
qui va de pair avec un certain nombre
d'évolutions de la société qui fait que
les exigences de ce métier
et sa complexité croissante qui va de
pair avec la complexité croissante de la
procédure pénale décourage l'évocation
et ça n'est pas une réorganisation même
bien faite
ce type de problème
c'est une réflexion
sur
la carrière le métier est peut-être même
aussi les avantages du métier
en contrepartie des contraintes
particulières qu'il impose quel est le
niveau des recrutements actuels par
rapport au passé et quand je dis niveau
c'est pas seulement une question
d'effectif c'est aussi une question de
qualification
des personnes qui se dirigent vers la
police judiciaire pourquoi y a-t-il si
je ne me trompe pas une préférence pour
d'autres missions au sein de la police
nationale avez-vous fait une analyse
approfondie de ces questions
Connaissez-vous les raisons pour
lesquelles
une telle situation si
vous en partager le constat existe voilà
mais deux questions donc code de
procédure pénale qu'est-ce que vous
attendez d'une réforme du code de
procédure pénale et l'évocation
comment les conforter merci dernière
intervention madame Boyer
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur
j'ai parvenir sur ce que mes collègues
ont dit sur leurs questions mais si je
peux me permettre un petit peu dans le
prolongement de la réflexion de mon
collègue Philippe Bas vous avez déploré
l'organisation en tuyau d'orgue et vous
pensez que la réforme que vous proposez
va permettre de l'améliorer mais ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il y a aussi une
crise de sens parce que l'organisation
en tuyau d'orgue le cloisonnement que
vous déplorez existe aussi dans le
continuum police
justice prison et comment mettre à
profit une réforme quelle que soit la
qualité de la réforme proposée quel que
soit les moyens proposés si aujourd'hui
et bien la justice soit ne suis pas au
suit mal et si surtout une fois les
enquêtes et lucides il n'y a pas de
suite donnée puisque on est toujours
dans dans cette difficult difficultés de
la prison du sens à la prison et de
l'effectivité des peines lorsque la
semaine dernière nous avons eu un
compte-rendu des travaux qui ont été
réalisés et qu'effectivement plusieurs
plusieurs personnes sont intervenues
dont le procureur molens
cette question effectivement de des
difficultés auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés tous et que déplore la police
sur la prison et donc l'effectivité de
la justice je pense est au coeur des
dispositifs et donc comment aujourd'hui
imaginer une telle réforme la réussite
du tel réforme donnait du sens à cette
réforme si elle ne s'inscrit pas dans un
continuum police justice prison
merci Madame voilà Monsieur le Directeur
12 intervenants autant de questions à
minima
ça fait la parole
merci monsieur le Président je vais
essayer de ne rien oublier dans la
réponse
même la rapporteur donc vous avez posé
une question sur le calendrier
je vous indique qu'on n'a pas de date je
vous avais passé ce sera certainement
pas le premier janvier ça je peux vous
le garantir
et ça ne sera pas au-delà du 31 décembre
mais il faut se laisser c'est une
réforme complexe
à mettre en oeuvre non seulement sur le
plan réglementaire
cartographie budgétaire de 88 des
emplois enfin
et il faut aussi encore laisser un peu
de temps
aux échanges
et nous avons l'ambition de terminer sa
mise en place avant l'échéance de la fin
de l'année 2023 pour nous consacrer
uniquement aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques en 2024 effectivement sur
les expérimentations
alors je distingue vraiment ce qui se
passe en outre-mer et ce qui se passe
dans l'Hexagone ou en métropole selon
l'expression qu'on souhaite employer et
donc on a d'ailleurs curieusement la
mise en place de cette réforme en
outre-mer n'a suscité aucune réaction de
nulle part pourtant on était confrontés
aux mêmes enjeux et
au même éventuels difficultés que celles
qui peuvent se présenter aujourd'hui
pour les perspectives en métropole donc
ça a été fait en janvier 2020 moi je
prends surtout alors je répondrai tout à
l'heure monsieur sénateur mais sur la
particularité des situations qu'il a
évoqué en outre-mer mais la Guyenne pour
nous et finalement le laboratoire qui se
rapproche le plus des situations dans
lesquelles on pourrait se retrouver en
déclinant cette réforme en métropole
avec la présence des quatre services que
je citer tout à l'heure
donc après quelques difficultés qu'on ne
peut pas ignorer dans toute
transformation de mise en place et de
changement de méthode et éventuellement
de responsabilité exercée on a
aujourd'hui une chaîne très fluide de
l'investigation de la prise de plainte
jusqu'au traitement des trafics les plus
élaborés ou des règlements de comptes
qu'on peut malheureusement observer dans
ce dans ce département avec des cadres
de la police judiciaire notamment qui
dorénavant s'implique aussi directement
sur ce qui se passe dès la prise de
plainte ou dès les constatations qui
sont opérées au moment où elle fait se
déroule et
un des objectifs de cette réforme
évidemment c'est de d'aborder cette
chaîne du traitement des infractions
des constatations des constatations ou
de la prise de plainte jusqu'au moment
où on va en faire peut-être une affaire
extrêmement complexe ou qui va rebondir
sur des enjeux autres que ceux qu'on
avait imaginé au départ et donc auprès
de moi
un chef de la mission outre-mer à la
direction générale de la police
nationale qui se trouve être l'ancien
directeur international de la prise
judiciaire antiguyane donc il connaît
bien en plus c'est ces territoires et
qui se déplacent très souvent pour et
pour le moment même si je vais le
week-end prochain en Guyane pour le
moment je me repose beaucoup sur ce
qu'il me dit de ce fonctionnement et il
me fait état de retour extrêmement
positifs et surtout pour les enquêteurs
qui sont en première ligne au niveau de
qui faisait le constat jusqu'à
maintenant
d'une certaine forme d'abandon de la
chenille archique puisque je l'indiqué
tout à l'heure le taux d'encadrement
pour la sécurité publique et très faible
et souvent on constate que pour le
premier le premier niveau de du
traitement de la délinquance les
enquêteurs sont souvent livrés un peu à
eux-mêmes
pas piloté pas encadré pas toujours
sélectionner en tout cas pas formé et
pas accompagné et c'est eux qui sont
dans le quotidien de la relation avec le
magistrat du parquet qui vient saisi et
donc le premier effet
bénéfique qu'on rencontre c'est la prise
en compte de cette chaîne et qui nous
paraît essentielle en plus dans le
fonctionnement
quotidien de la politicienne il y a
évidemment le traitement des affaires
complexes mais des affaires complexes
qui se nourrissent aussi de tout petit
fait du quotidien et de la connaissance
qu'on peut avoir du terrain par la
présence quand certains effectifs de la
sécurité publique sur le terrain donc en
matière de partage de renseignements
c'est aussi un progrès considérable et
puis pour on a des bases communes
dorénavant là où elle n'existait pas
auparavant des bases communes pour
exploiter les renseignements et des
bases communes pour
voilà pour faire des rapprochements
éventuels entre différents faits qui au
départ
nous relèverait pas peut-être pas d'une
même organisation ou d'un même d'un même
enchaînement après sur les éléments les
éléments négatifs
objectivement sur tout ce qui concerne
outre-mer j'ai pas de j'ai pas de retour
j'ai pas de bilan négatif je répondrai
aussi là un petit peu en particulier sur
les questions qui m'ont été posées
puisque la Commission s'est déplacée
dans deux territoires au-delà même la
mission enfin un produit judiciaire que
nous examinons aujourd'hui on a
évidemment beaucoup d'effets positifs
sur d'autres métiers de la police
nationale comme l'ordre public ou le
traitement de l'immigration immigration
irrégulière pour ce qui est de la
métropole je l'ai indiqué la difficulté
de ces expérimentations c'est qu'elle
repose beaucoup sur la personnalité
des préfigurateurs et sur la manière
dont les choses s'organisent localement
et mon effectivement pour ce qui est de
la métropole on a des départements où ça
fonctionne très bien
et des départements ça fonctionne moins
bien ça peut être pour des questions de
personnes ou de manière d'aborder des
choses ça peut être aussi de singularité
locale
typiquement si on prend le département
du Pas-de-Calais l'action de l'antenne
de police judiciaire local les sur le
littoral puisque elle est implantée à
Coquelles à côté de Calais et donc elle
n'a pas de vrai compétences exercées sur
l'ensemble du département du
Pas-de-Calais pour nous citer que que
cet exemple il y a parfois eu aussi des
tentatives de la part de certains
préfigurateurs de faire faire des
missions qui ne rentrait pas dans le
périmètre de ce qui avait été défini
donc ça fait l'objet de rappel à l'ordre
donc on voit bien que nous ce qu'on tire
de ces pratiques c'est qu'on a vraiment
besoin d'un d'une doctrine d'un document
qui fixe très précisément
à la fois l'émission de chacun les
objectifs qu'on leur assigne et donc une
fois qu'on a fini tout ça l'organisation
qui doit qui doit se mettre qui doit se
mettre en place alors vous avez indiqué
parmi les craintes qui sont exprimées
effectivement le une des craintes qui
s'ouvre en mise en avant c'est de dire
la peau judiciaire finalement on va se
diluer dans
[Musique]
dans la masse des affaires que traite la
sécurité publique avec les contraintes
qui sont celles de la sécurité publique
et qu'on ne peut pas qu'on ne peut pas
ignorer c'est pour ça que
j'ai pris des engagements ferme en la
matière notamment pour tout ce qui
relève
du traitement des stocks de procédure et
faire en sorte que
voilà il n'y ait pas de tentation de la
part d'un cadre qui n'aurait pas compris
les objectifs qui lui ont été fixés de
voilà de s'écarter de s'écarter de des
règles et un autre point positif que
j'ai oublié pour l'outre-mer c'est que
souvent ils nous étaient reprochés par
exemple j'ai parlé de du département de
la Guyane il nous était reprochés à
l'époque où j'ai exercé déjà de ne pas
être présent à la réunion en Polynésie
française et donc quand notamment les
les parquets ou les jeux d'instructions
locaux voulaient saisir un service
spécialisé dans le domaine économique et
financier en fait il réservait
saisine de manière très exceptionnelle à
l'office central en poste à Paris et
donc cet office central envoyer des
enquêteurs pour faire les perquisitions
qui repartaient avec les éléments et qui
revenaient quelques semaines ou quelques
mois plus tard procéder au garde-à-vis
et avec la mise en place de cette
réforme en outre-mer on a créé un
troisième niveau d'investigation à la
Réunion et bientôt en Polynésie en Y en
voyant sur place des enquêteurs
économiques et financiers breveté par la
Direction Centrale judiciaire donc ça
nous a permis de créer en fait des
moyens d'investigation qui qui
n'existaient pas qui n'existait pas
auparavant
[Musique]
vous avez posé une question à propos de
la direction nationale de la police
judiciaire les directions centrales
jusqu'à maintenant ont aussi l'aspect
gestion des ressources humaines pour
les effectifs dont ils ont la charge
avec
un effet très négatif c'est-à-dire que
les avancements les mutations les
parcours de carrière ne sont considérés
que sous le prisme de la direction à
laquelle ils appartiennent j'ai un
exemple que je cite souvent que les
directeurs concernés me pardonnent pour
moi il est absolument révélateur parfois
du caractère un peu ubuesque de notre
organisation j'ai eu le cas quand j'ai
pris mes fonctions de 3 commandants de
police chef de Berry qui quittait la
DCPJ exerçant des responsabilités
importantes très bien notées pour
rejoindre des postes de coopérant à
l'étranger à la Direction de la
Coopération internationale de sécurité
ils étaient éligibles à un avancement
donc moi le directeur central de la
préjudiciaire m'a dit moi il s'en vont
ils le méritent ils sont compétents mais
ils s'en vont je ne les propose pas
et la directrice centrale de la
coopération internationale de sécurité
m'a dit
ils sont sans doute très bon puisqu'on
les a choisis ils vont occuper des
postes à responsabilités mais moi je les
propose pas parce qu'ils arrivent
est-ce qu'ils ont des mérites ou est-ce
qu'ils n'en n'ont pas voilà est-ce que
leur ancienneté justifie soit proposée
donc j'ai exigé de la part du directeur
central de la policière qui ne fasse des
propositions d'avancement dans un ordre
prioritaire pour ces trois commandants
de police c'est pour moi révélateur de
cette organisation cloisonnée et
d'ailleurs je me permets d'assister au
travers des observations que vous avez
faites
mesdames Messieurs les créateur c'est
souvent quand on parle de cette réforme
on oublie quand même
ce qui nous a amené à l'envisager et la
manière dont les diagnostics ont été
posées par d'autres que nous
[Musique]
le monde met en oeuvre cette stratégie
avec des objectifs clairs des moyens
adaptés et des moyens qui puissent être
utilisés par chacun avec des formations
et des outils de pilotage qui nous
permettent d'y voir clair voilà nous on
n'est pas des outils de pilotage qui se
différencent selon les directions
concernées et donc ce directeur national
ou cette directrice nationale de la
police judiciaire demain sera le le
garant de du fonctionnement de cet
ensemble et de la bonne cohérence de cet
ensemble de l'efficacité de cet enfant
vous avez posé une question même le
rapporteur aussi sur le choix
d'enquêteur je crois que j'ai répondu de
toute façon non seulement ça n'était pas
nos intentions on n'avait pas l'ambition
de réécrire le code de procédure pénal
peut-être pour répondre à d'autres
questions
il mériterait sans doute mais en tout
cas pour tout ce qui relève de la
direction de la police judiciaire du
contrôle de la police judiciaire et du
livre choix du magistrat du service
enquêteur évidemment il est hors de au
niveau d'imaginer qu'on puisse faire
qu'on puisse faire autrement
monsieur leur rapporteur vous avez
évoqué la levée de boucliers massive
dépend la définition qu'on donne à la
masse
[Musique]
bon j'observe quand même que elle
concerne une partie des enquêteurs de la
police judiciaire c'est pas parce que
ils ne sont pas très nombreux rapportés
à la masse des policiers de cette
administration que évidemment leurs
inquiétudes de nos pas être prises en
compte donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
essayé dans un document bien sûr je
partagerai avec avec la mission
de répondre à certaines des
interrogations de manière la plus
concrète et d'après la plus directe
possible
vous évoquez aussi le CNB bon moi je
suis toujours
étonné de voir le Conseil National des
Barreaux s'intéresser au fonctionnement
de la police mais pourquoi pas je pense
qu'ils n'ont pas une bonne connaissance
de ce que nous projetons pour ce qui est
de la conférence des procureurs je dois
quand même préciser à la commission que
je me suis adressé évidemment au bureau
de la conférence de procureurs pour leur
expliquer le sens de la réforme je me
suis adressé au bureau de la conférence
et pour que leur généraux alors c'était
une époque malheureusement les échanges
étaient compliqués c'était en vieux
conférence et j'ai eu grâce à la
Chancellerie l'opportunité de m'adresser
à l'ensemble des procureurs de la
République et des procureurs généraux au
tribunal judiciaire de Paris l'ensemble
de ces magistrats représentants toutes
les toutes les juridiques par ailleurs
dans le cadre de l'équipe projet on a
proposé à la chancellerie de nous
déléguer un magistrat pour intégrer
l'équipe projet pour être certain que
tous les aspects de cette réforme
prendrait en compte les attentes les
questions les inquiétudes que pourrait
exprimer la magistrature bon ils n'ont
pas été en capacité de le faire pour des
raisons d'organisation interne mais pour
autant nous avons un magistrat du bureau
de la police judiciaire de la DSCG qui
est identifié avec lequel l'équipe
projet de la DGPN a des contacts
extrêmement réguliers moi-même dans le
cadre de mes déplacements dans les
directions de la police judiciaire je
prends le soin d'aller voir
les procureurs de la République du
ressort
et le président du tribunal dans un
format qui lui-même évidemment décide de
de définir donc voilà nous il nous
paraît incontournable le fait que
la justice doit être associée à ce
projet doit bien en comprendre tous les
enjeux et à chaque fois j'aime rappeler
mais je crois que c'est important c'est
évidemment que le sujet de la police
judiciaire est des déchets que traite la
police judiciaire est important qu'on ne
doit renoncer à rien et qu'on doit être
attentif à ce que seront nos défis de
demain mais je regarde tout le reste je
regarde tout le reste qui est quand même
le quotidien de la
d'abord des de la population c'est à
dire que quand quelqu'un se fait
arracher son sac ou son collier dans la
rue il se demande pas si c'est un dealer
du coin un SDF un voleur d'habitude ou
un membre d'un groupe criminel organisé
qui vient qui vient des Balkans ou d'une
autre région de l'Europe de l'Est ce que
veut ce que veut cette victime c'est
d'être bien accueilli dans un
commissariat que ça plainte soit traitée
éventuellement d'être informé de la
manière dont l'enquête se déroule et
surtout d'avoir la perspective
que l'auteur soit arrêté et d'obtenir
réparation du préjudice qu'elle a subi
donc et je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est la direction centrale de la
sécurité publique si on s'en réfère aux
agrégats du de la statistique qui traite
l'essentiel des faits de criminalité
organisée dont on sait malheureusement
pour certaines de ces organisations
criminelles que elles tirent leur profit
surtout de la multiplication de tout
petits faits voilà et de manière
itinérante donc nous avons l'obligation
aussi d'avoir cette capacité à analyser
de manière syrienne un ensemble de
petits faits qui pris isolément ne vont
pas peut-être justifier qu'un parquet
engage des poursuites mais réunies vont
nous permettre d'avoir un impact pénal
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus important
monsieur rapporteur vous avez parlé de
du lien entre
le préfet et les politiques alors je
crois que mon intervention d'hier sur
France 2 a été mal comprise
pour avoir exercer ses fonctions pendant
quatre ans j'en retire une certaine
fierté et je pense que les préfets enfin
je pense je suis convaincu je suis
certain que les préfets sont des grands
serviteurs de l'État et de la République
et de préjugés que les préfets se
mêleraient d'enquête judiciaire au
regard des relations qu'ils
entretiennent localement avec des élus
et est un joyeux je parle je dis pas ça
pour vous hein
c'est dans ce que ce qui est dit dans
quelques observations quelques craintes
qui sont exposées notamment par des
syndicats de magistrats
voilà le préfet le représentant de
chacun des membres du gouvernement dans
le territoire c'est peut-être à ce titre
là qui est en relation avec des
politiques enfin localement je pense que
les préfets ne sont pas soumis à la
pression des politiques en tout cas
certaines n'ont pas dans le cadre
d'un suivi éventuel de procédure
judiciaire par ailleurs si je me réfère
au fonctionnement de Paris voilà le
préfet de police de Paris il a sous son
majorité la direction régionale la plus
judiciaire de Paris qui compte une
brigade financière bon je n'ai jamais
entendu dire que les préfets de police
se mêlaient des enquêtes judiciaires
ils ne sont pas évalués là-dessus et je
pense qu'avec dans le cadre du contrôle
social qui est aujourd'hui en place si
un jour cela devait se passer ça serait
évidemment immédiatement et par ailleurs
à mon niveau à mon niveau je dépends
directement de l'autorité du ministère
j'ai à côté de moi un directeur central
de la plus judiciaire qui est placé sous
mon autorité qui a les services les plus
spécialisés dans la lutte contre la
délinquance économique et financière je
ne mêle pas de la manière dont les
enquêtes sont conduites donc je crois
qu'il faut enfin tout le monde à présent
à l'esprit dans la police et dans le
corps préfectoral la répartition des
compétences et des prérogatives et ce
qui revient à chacun de faire
[Musique]
tout le temps attaché que lui mais pour
le reste qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour le reste moi je
j'entends personne parler de du sujet de
la petite et moyenne des vacances qui
ouvre quand même l'essentiel aujourd'hui
et ce que je dis à mes interlocuteurs
que je rencontre dans mes déplacements
c'est nous fait pas d'illusion si ça
craque
pour les sujets de petites et moyennes
délinquance et bon sur la définition
moyen d'éloquence on pourrait sans doute
discuter discuter du terme quelqu'un qui
qui se fait cambrioler ou qui se fait
agresser dans la rue est-ce que c'est la
moyenne des vacances j'en suis pas sûr
je pense que ça va ça va entraîner tout
le reste ça va entraîner tout le reste
tout le reste avec donc
[Musique]
je me suis pas caché je moi j'ai posé
les constats qui sont faits par d'autres
les constats que nous faisons nous au
quotidien les constats qui ont été faits
par les commissions du Sénat l'Assemblée
par la Cour des comptes et par d'autres
qui s'intéressent au fonctionnement des
services de sécurité intérieure donc
en ma qualité du directeur général de la
professionnelle je peux pas me contenter
de dire je garde d'un côté ce qui
fonctionne bien mais pour tout le reste
ben finalement on continue comme avant
et j'attends que mon successeur s'occupe
de traiter de traiter le problème donc
notre ambition notre objectif c'est de
protéger et de garantir ce qui marche
bien et de s'appuyer sur les méthodes et
les principes qui font qui font de
l'efficacité de la police judiciaire
pour les appliquer à l'ensemble de la
chaîne et pour faire en sorte que
quelques cadres de la police
qui se sont investis dans ces métiers
par vocation qui ont acquis des
compétences d'expérience
s'investissent voilà sur toute la chaîne
nous mettions changés les protocoles
portes et carrière ont changé quand j'ai
été jeune commissaire de police à la
police judiciaire je partais faire des
perquisitions des plans que des voilà
c'est je faisais des gardes à vue
c'était ça le travail d'un commissaire
de police comme les inspecteurs à
l'époque et on avait très peu
d'équivalent gardien de la peste des
enquêteurs de police à l'époque on a eu
une grande réforme Corse et carrière qui
a fait diminuer le nombre de
commissaires de police qui a fait
diminuer le nombre de fichiers de police
et qui a conduit aussi et qui a augmenté
le niveau de responsabilité du corps
d'encadrement et d'application
en redéfinissant l'émission et le rôle
de chacun et donc aujourd'hui la
fonction d'un commissaire d'un officier
de police sauf peut-être quelques
situations très spécialisées c'est
d'abord d'encadrer de piloter voilà de
fixer des objectifs d'être des
interlocuteurs
de l'autorité judiciaire et ne pas
laisser les enquêteurs dont on a la
responsabilité se débrouiller avec les
difficultés les difficultés qui
rencontrent et
vous avez évoqué monsieur rapporteur
aussi la réduction des capacités à ce
projeter nous nous rédigons pas la les
capacités à nous projeter d'abord parce
que les offices centraux on y touche pas
et qui a aussi des antennes des offices
centraux un peu partout dans les
dans les territoires et parce que j'ai
pris l'engagement de maintenir partout
où il se trouve les implantations de la
police judiciaire avec les mêmes
compétences territoriales et les mêmes
les mêmes comp
je sais pas si on a trop le temps
monsieur le Président juste évoquer le
une situation personnelle que j'ai connu
à Marseille j'étais chef de la division
des stupéfiants et des proxénétisme à
Marseille mais c'est vrai il y a un
petit peu il y a quelques années et donc
pour être efficace on imaginait que on
avait des groupes qui faisaient le
trafic international mais pour être
efficace sur le trafic international il
faut savoir ce qui se passe aussi un
petit peu sur le terrain parce que c'est
de là qu'on récupère nos renseignements
donc on avait des groupes cités déjà à
l'époque et bien avant la préjudiciaire
aussi récupéré les mises à disposition
qui était faite par la sécurité publique
mais c'était devenu tellement important
que finalement la sécurité publique
avait récupéré cet aspect là ce qu'on
appelait le ramassage et donc à partir
du ramassage comme on a les
renseignements qui augmentent finalement
la sécurité publique s'est mis elle
aussi à traiter les mêmes dossiers à des
dossiers de cité et on s'est retrouvé en
concurrence les mêmes services de police
judiciaire et les services de la de la
sécurité publique au même endroit donc à
signer un protocole à mettre des
instances de coordination et à se
disputer les objectifs et les objectifs
et les et les renseignements donc ça me
paraît pas être une
voilà un danger et on a vraiment besoin
de
d'avoir de
la coordination de une répartition des
tâches et des missions qui soient qui
soit cohérentes et qu'on ne soit pas à
plusieurs à traiter les mêmes sujets
vous avez parlé vous avez fait référence
à la locmi je pense qu'on est enfin pour
nous sur deux démarches très différentes
on a on attend beaucoup de la lovni vous
le savez
auditionné il y a quelques jours
évidemment sur l'aspect budgétaire mais
mais pas que on a une dimension
juridique très très importante
je pense que j'aurais l'occasion de
répondre à un de vos collègues sur la
question des assistants enquêtes voilà
en particulier mais pas que sur toute
tout ce qui ressort de la simplification
du code de procès OpenAL on a évidemment
beaucoup d'attentes de la part de la
avec en plus une dimension importante
puisque certains
certaines sénatrices sont en ont parlé
c'est les renforts on a quand même là
aussi une politique de renfort qui en
termes de ressources humaines qui se qui
se profile
madame la sénatrice vous avez
révoqué le cloisonnement étanche des
services malheureusement c'est une
réalité que nous vivons tous les jours
vous avez évoqué la période du
confinement et du cloisonnement
effectivement ça nous a permis
typiquement pour la police frontière
mais parce que bon le directeur général
en avait donné l'instruction avec le
directeur central de la police aux
frontières étaient bien sûr évidemment
tout à fait disposé à le faire des
effectifs de la direction centrale de la
République aux frontières sont à des
patrouillées sur le terrain aux côtés
des effectifs de la sécurité publique
puisque les activités aux aéroports
étaient quasi nuls et de la même façon
dans les dans les dans les ports et même
les centres de rétention administratifs
étaient étaient
ne fonctionnait plus de manière de
manière classique
et Mayotte Mayotte je pourrais pas
répondre à un monsieur le sénateur mais
typiquement alors là c'était pas un
objectif de police judiciaire c'était
plutôt un objectif à la fois faire face
aux violences de te rappeler monsieur le
sénateur et le flot de migrants
irréguliers qui arrive
quotidiennement dans l'île et que la
police aux frontières se doit de
renvoyer de manière aussi quotidienne à
destination des Comores et donc ça
permet dorénavant au directeur
départemental de la police nationale en
fonction des situations auxquelles il
est confrontées ou de faire appel à la
page pour renforcer les services en
charge de l'ordre public ou
réciproquement de faire appel aux
services en charge de République pour
renforcer les services de la PAF pour
effectuer les les
retours dans les meilleurs dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
donc
vous sembliez douter de l'augmentation
du nombre d'enquêteurs alors je vous
assure qu'il n'y a pas de de chiffre
makis moi aussi je
m'en suis inquiété parce que quand on va
devant le Sénat ou l'Assemblée nationale
on a mis à être certain de ces chiffres
alors on fait la différence entre des
chiffres budgétaires d'ailleurs ou
parfois on donne une mission de police
judiciaire à à des agents qui n'exerce
pas véritablement une fonction d'enquête
nous c'est vraiment concentré sur ceux
qui ont sur les agents qu'on consacré à
la mission d'investigation ce qui
faisait des qui traitaient des
procédures et ce sont des chiffres qui
nous ont été communiqués par les
directions centrales concernées donc ils
peuvent être discutés évidemment
parallèlement quand même vous noterez
que on nous inscrivons dans une démarche
d'augmentation du nombre d'officiers de
police judiciaires une question m'a été
posée à ce propos je vais je vais y
revenir tout à l'heure
les assistants d'enquêtes est-ce que
c'est une bonne idée c'est une
excellente idée d'autant plus que je
dois vous le voyez que je suis un peu à
l'initiative et je vais un peu poussé
cette idée mais c'était surtout
confronté à la situation que rappeler je
crois monsieur
ministre le bas c'est si vous voulez dès
qu'on fait des réformes pour simplifier
la procédure en fait les les enquêteurs
ont le sentiment que on ressort surtout
davantage avec plus de contraintes que
que moins de contraintes donc l'idée
c'était de dégager du temps enquêteur de
des actes purement formels de la
procédure
et s'appuyer sur le modèle
des jeux d'instructions avec des
qualifiés de justice et faire faire un
certain nombre d'actes qui consiste à
appeler l'avocat appeler le médecin la
vie affami même la rédaction d'un
certain nombre de réquisition qui qui
aujourd'hui alors je ne vais pas de
statistiques très très scientifique mais
occupe un tiers des un tiers en fait de
du temps de la procédure notamment
pendant la garde à vue et je peux vous
dire que c'est une mesure qui est très
favorablement accueillie dans les
services que ce soit les services
spécialisés ou des services généraliste
comme la sécurité publique
est-ce que c'est raisonnable de faire la
réforme maintenant
vous qui êtes-vous placé que moi pour le
savoir au Sénat c'est jamais le moment
de faire une réforme on a toujours de
bonnes raisons de pas les faire
[Musique]
ou
si il y a des élections à terme ou il y
a des événements voilà je pense qu'à un
moment il faut avoir le courage quand on
fait un diagnostic moi je me j'ai aucun
intérêt ou un jeu personnel bien sûr
dans ce dans ce projet à partir du
moment où on a identifié des difficultés
à partir du moment où on les constat
quotidiennement sur le terrain où on dit
on essaie de de faire des initiés des
mesures très ponctuelles on essaie au
contraire de de redonner une dynamique
et de redonner un peu de sens pour
reprendre une expression qui a été
étudiée tout à l'heure mais je pense
qu'on a pas le choix quoi on le où on
l'a fait en 2023 on a fait on la fera
jamais
[Musique]
est parti quand
il me parlait de la présence sur le
terrain et
du fait que on avait besoin pour
prévenir de d'avoir aussi des
politiciens sur le terrain c'est tout le
sens des instructions que nous donne le
ministre de l'Intérieur
de manière répétée on a fait en sorte
que cela soit possible notamment avec la
réforme des cyclorets notamment la mise
en oeuvre d'un cycle binaire qui
dorénavant se généralise et nous permet
d'avoir plus de présence policière sur
le terrain d'un certain nombre de
renforts aussi qui ont été accordés par
le ministre intérieur dans certaines
circonscriptions de police que ce soit
des renforts permanents ou des renforts
au travers de compagnies de CRS ou
d'escadron de gendarmerie qui sont
envoyés dans certaines métropoles et
demain demain nous l'espérons la
présence importante de réserviste de la
police nationale
qui est à la fois viendront apporter un
concours décisif aux missions de police
mais aussi nous continuerons j'en suis
sûr à renforcer le lien police
population
monsieur le sénateur alors je clique où
c'est parti pour pour vous répondre sur
ces questions
relatives à l'Outre-mer qui me sont très
très cher
je vous remercie d'avoir souligné les
effets positifs
en Guyane et à Mayotte pas pour les
mêmes raisons et pas pour les mêmes
problèmes sans doute c'est vrai que nous
sommes confrontés à des flambées de
violence alors
à Mayotte plutôt autour des questions
dans le public et
en Guyane plutôt autour des questions de
délinquance le ministre à l'intérieur va
se déplacer en Guyane le week-end
prochain donc je suppose que il aura des
évidemment des annonces à faire à
l'occasion de se déplacement je crois
qu'effectivement la réforme nous a donné
la capacité d'être
pardon
voilà de jouer ce que j'expliquais tout
à l'heure à Mayotte notamment entre la
PAF et la sécurité publique leur public
selon les questions migratoires ou les
questions de vente publique de jouer
entre les de jouer entre les forces la
CDI je vous confirme que les mises en
place à Mayotte et qu'elle fonctionne et
que j'ai bien conscience que de
permettre à des territoires de devenir
circonscription de police est une
attente forte des élus locaux notamment
à kombu mais c'est une décision
évidemment qui n'appartient pas au
directeur généralisationnel qui
appartient au gouvernement sur la
cybercriminalité monsieur le Center
alors nous allons dévoiler un plan cyber
dans les dans les jours ou dans les
semaines qui viennent donc je ne suis
pas certain que ça soit vraiment le
moment de d'en faire état mais on vous
communiquera tous les éléments
je voudrais souligner notamment avec le
dispositif
d'escroquerie en ligne
qui est un fléau qui a tendance à se
répandre à ce généraliser et nous avons
mis en place depuis le mois de mars
cette année donc la possibilité de
peinte en ligne c'est la première
plainte en ligne aujourd'hui disponible
dans notre pays
pour les usagers qui offrent plusieurs
avantages d'abord la facilité pour les
victimes de pouvoir effectuer cette
plainte en ligne et souvent des
escroqueries sur Internet évidemment se
multiplient et provoque des prises de
plainte dispersées un peu partout sur
les international multipliant les
enquêtes sans forcément une grande
cohérence là ça nous permet de faire des
rapprochements et d'initier une seule
enquête là où auparavant on en faisait
25 ou 30 sur le même sur le même sujet
donc Thésée est vraiment la
démonstration je crois de ce que nous
devons mettre en place pour l'avenir
monsieur le sénateur je vous remercie
des compliments adressés pour ma
conclusion mais
oui oui mais
[Musique]
par contre voilà je refais la réponse à
propos de ce qu'a dit monsieur le
procureur général près la Cour de
cassation
je pense que les problèmes doivent être
traités dans leur ensemble de vouloir
simplement les traiter les petits bouts
par petits bouts ça nous aide pas
beaucoup à avancer donc évidemment je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure mon dialogon
avec le ministère de justice ça me
paraît absolument nécessaire avec les
magistrats sur place j'ai dit on a des
échanges avec la DSCG
donc pour nous le également le principe
d'indépendance de la justice c'est un
principe auquel personne ne peut déroger
vous vous avez parlé de la complexité de
la procédure pénale
si vous suivez parfois on a le sentiment
que des alors même que des projets des
propositions de loi nous paraissent
aller dans le bon sens quelques
amendements viennent compliquer ou
rajouter de la de la difficulté
voilà mais c'est aussi parfois les
l'effet de la jurisprudence que nous
prenons en compte et de toute façon les
les normes européennes aussi les normes
juridiques européennes vont s'imposer à
nous il faut qu'on y réfléchisse ce qui
est sûr c'est que quand on regarde la
manière dont
l'épaisseur du code de procédure pénale
et du code pénal pas le code pénal c'est
c'est moins gênant mais du coup de
procédures pénales en quelques années
montre qu'aujourd'hui ça devient un
chantier enfin dont j'ai compris que le
garde des sceaux voulait s'emparer tout
à fait tout à fait indispensable vous
avez parlé évidemment
d'affaires d'ampleur national ou
internationales je n'ai pas le temps de
développer mais j'ai connu donc
Marseille une époque où c'était des
Corses ou des ou des Lyonnais ou des
Parisiens qui venaient tuer des voyous
marseillais aujourd'hui
ça se joue entre la Castellane
la paternelle
et certaines équipes que ceux qui
travaillent là-bas le connaissent avec
des enjeux qui sont davantage locaux
ce qu'on pourrait décrire au niveau
national ou international ça ne nous
empêche pas évidemment d'envisager que
au travers de l'activité des groupes
criminels les choses aussi se placent au
niveau national et international
l'organisation de la DCPJ qui sera la
même pour la dnp-hi nous garantit que
nous pourrons aussi les aborder avec un
problème supplémentaire en écho à ce que
disait monsieur le sénateur tout à
l'heure c'est avec l'explosion de la
cybercriminalité demain une grosse
partie de cette délinquance sera
évidemment virtualiser et donc la
question de la compétence territoriale
sera un sujet un sujet bien bien
secondaire
[Musique]
que vous étiez mal à l'aise face à mon
propos ou que j'avais considéré que
c'était circulé il n'y a rien à voir bon
je vous redis que nous nous appuyons sur
des rapports sur des diagnostics sur
celui je l'ai évoqué tribirment mais qui
a été fait par le Livre blanc de la
sécurité intérieure qui est quand même
un document assez riche qu'on me dont on
peut discuter
je veux dire les décisions qui sont qui
sont proposées par ce livre blanc mais
enfin moi je constate
sur les constats à peu près tout le
monde se rejoint voilà et que
certains proposent des solutions en
général toujours la même et d'autres
n'en proposent aucune voilà moi je suis
partisan de
trouver une solution aux problèmes et
qui se pose évidemment qu'une réforme
doit être comprise je suis d'accord avec
vous j'essaie de le faire du mieux
possible avec
les mots qui sont les miens dans une
organisation qui est celle de la police
nationale où on a un système hiérarchisé
voilà c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un
club c'est pas c'est pas un forum voilà
c'est une
administration où s'exerce l'autorité où
on emploie la force ou chacun à son
niveau doit exercer ses responsabilités
doit les assumer et exercer ses
responsabilités c'est aussi expliquer le
sens des décisions qui sont prises
écoutez les observations qui sont faites
par celles et ceux qui qui posent des
questions et les faire remonter et de la
même manière
on doit pouvoir dans le cas du dialogue
social qui est parfois un peu compliqué
on a des organisations syndicales qui
peuvent être turbulantes dans la police
nationale mais j'en accepte le principe
c'est un fonctionnement sain qui qui
tienne leur légitimité d'un vote et avec
lesquels au travers d'instance qui se
réunissent aussi bien dans le cadre d'un
dialogue social continu nous font
remonter nous font remonter un certain
nombre de choses donc vous avez dit
[Musique]
voilà qui a un problème de ressources
humaines mais je effectivement cette
nous on a eu des renforts on fait des
efforts de formation d'officier de
police judiciaires on a sans doute des
efforts supplémentaires à faire on va le
faire avec l'Académie de Police la
création de l'Académie de Police que je
n'ai pas évoqué vous m'avez posé une
question sur sur la Corse alors j'avoue
que j'étais sur la police je sais pas il
y avait des annonces qui ont été faites
ce matin ou pour la police en Corse
qui m'a échappé on a nos
projets sur l'organisation de la police
encore ça part celui que je porte pour
la pour la direction générale de la
police nationale
monsieur le ministre vous avez parlé de
la simplification de la procédure pénale
indispensable pour faciliter la tâche
des enquêteurs je ne peux qu'adhérer à
cette observation je les je l'ai indiqué
vous avez évoqué une crise possible
d'évocation c'est un constat que nous
faisons
je l'indiqué nous y avons travaillé au
travers de cette coordination nationale
de l'investigation pour bien identifier
l'ensemble des problèmes auxquels nous
sommes confrontés j'y vois notamment je
pense que la mission de police
judiciaire c'est la dernière mission
dans la police nationale vous êtes
responsable personnellement de ce que
vous faites
vous devez des comptes évidemment à
votre chef et vous devez des comptes au
magistrats qui vous a saisi vous devez
des comptes
à la société à l'avocat à la presse qui
va éventuellement vous interpeller sur
votre action personnelle à l'occasion
d'un procès donc c'est sans doute
quelque chose de difficile à assumer
pour tous les enquêteurs c'est aussi ce
sont des métiers qui appellent une
disponibilité très très grande
[Musique]
nous y travaillons dans d'autres cadres
pour essayer de susciter de l'intérêt
d'évocations et le fait d'ailleurs de
permettre cette formation de PJ dès
l'école de gardien de la paix et pour
nous aussi une invitation peut-être à
certains jeunes gens ou jeunes filles
qui hésitent à rentrer dans la police en
se disant je vais faire du police
secours pendant 5 ans pendant 10 ans
avant de pouvoir rejoindre une unité
d'investigation si je fais ma formation
d'epj je suis au PJ 30 mois après que je
sois rentré à l'école j'ai la
possibilité d'intégrer un service
d'investigation et moi ce qui me plaît
c'est de faire l'investigation je pense
qu'on a encore des heureusement des
candidats pour pour le faire
et votre dernière question
c'était voilà c'était sur le niveau des
recrutements et
il nous faut sans doute il a aussi
imaginer d'autres formes de recrutement
effectivement il y a une variété un
panel de métiers à la police la police
judiciaire le renseignement l'ordre
public l'international qui font que les
choix sont très larges mais on voit bien
quand même toujours
et heureusement d'ailleurs un intérêt
toujours constant pour tout ce qui
touche tout ce qui touche à
l'investigation
même c'est un fils
vous avez déploré de l'organisation
tuyau d'orgue avec la justice et
l'administration pénitentiaire
vous avez observé que c'était déjà très
compliqué de les régler pour la police
nationale donc je vais d'abord essayer
de franchir cet obstacle avant de
m'attaquer de m'attaquer aux autres
voilà mais évidemment nous sommes très
attachés continuum de sécurité de
d'ailleurs avec les élus aussi les
polices municipales jusqu'au jusqu'à la
décision finale
de la de la sanction et de son exécution
merci beaucoup monsieur le directeur
pour l'ensemble de ces précisions qui je
crois sont appréciées par la Commission
en particulier par le détail de des
informations que vous nous donnez y
compris parfois vous doutes mais surtout
le constat qui semble être assez
largement partagé sur le dernier point
qui a été soulevé sur la crise
d'évocations en matière de police
judiciaire on le constate maintenant
depuis plusieurs années
c'est exact il y a sans doute aussi un
changement de culture dans le dans la
capacité de vouloir s'investir 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7 c'est probable et
aussi prolon un problème de statut
peut-être de rémunération de
reconnaissance de la difficulté de cette
partie de la police qui nécessite
peut-être mais ça c'est un autre sujet
un regard particulier contenu de
l'engagement que cela nécessite en tous
les cas merci pour pour tout cela les
rapporteurs vont continuer de travailler
et nous devrions en principe pouvoir
produire un rapport dans le courant de
dans quelques semaines
et on va les faire travailler un peu un
peu fort voilà merci à vous en tous les
cas chers collègues la Commission est
levée je vous remercie